alors oui ce temps ça va ça va bien et
tu trouves comment ils sont caïd nom en
forme en forme après et encore on dit
pas leur âge parce que si on disait le
rush pouvoir encore beaucoup plus en
forme tu vas tu relis toi présente
treize lots
à 12h30 il ya le peuple du maire de la
ville vient vw
ça résume thierry du fait très jeunes
jouent à la 38 ans à la foule attaque
oui et non parce à son âge à lui c'est
ça qui est prévu maintenant taquet l'a26
ben ça va hein c'est la moitié de jean
lefebvre
alors j'ai attaqué très marrant c'est
que fumer à domrémy gilles bloch
belgique rugby à 7 ans pète c'est bon
pour un imitateur un mec qui fait des
voix est né dans l'ain dans le bled de
jeanne d'arc c'est quand même incroyable
c'est vrai mais c'est un truc pour les
journaliers moi c'est plus un truc moi
c'est plus sûr tout pour les
journalistes
ouais en fait t'es pas allé du dos a
quand même pas du tout chômé bar le duc
et puis en fait j'ai vécu toute mon
enfance mon enfance à côté de doremi sl
1 4 km tous les journalistes fait la
musique c'est son grand père qui l'a
initié à la musique et puis son frère
aussi
ouais et tout petits à l'âge de 12 ans
enfant de la balle il jouait déjà dans
les bals c'est ça froisse et toi ça va
pas si vite que ça j'ai commencé à
chanter
ouais sur les chansons de michel sardou
ouais et j'ai appris à chanter là c'est
la maman
et puis il est monté à paris
voilà j'ai la puberté a beaucoup galéré
pas trop non à ben alors maintenant
alors aujourd'hui tu es sûr qu'elles
cèdent à la comédie caumartin pour une
pièce qui s'appelle comment meurtre au
music hall avait un truc qui est drôle
c'est que la plupart des imitateurs
-bon design sur scène ils font des voix
les unes après les autres et toi aussi
oui d'accord mais en face il ya scénario
c'est ça qui est drôle c'est c'était une
intrigue policière ça s'appelle meurtre
magical est une vraie intrigue policière
et petit à petit comme ça tu fais toutes
tes voix mais sur un sur un thème quoi
sur un thème et je veux dire ils ont
tous un roulé s'est on a fait un super
casting quoi oui à johnny hallyday va
justement j'ai de faire une interview
loulou ouzou où selon ses goûts de
balance des noms comme ça use ou non
mais ce qu'on prend le relais mais c'est
vous ou comment tu l'as dit oiseaux
japonais et virales ou alors on commence
michel galabru
alors si on fait du burida il a un rôle
mais quand dira de chez le directeur du
théâtre et itil un peu ferme où sont les
premiers producteurs un gentil j'en tire
un peu sur le podium
ouais johnny hallyday moi je suis le
flic
ouais
paul peut le prévoir à moi je suis
concierge était à + travail avec
monsieur avec michel galabru et je dire
qu'ils qui ne fait pas beaucoup comme
moi je suis je travaille dans
l'hyperespace je travaille dans un hyper
cosmence autres puisque je suis le sous
fifre de deux ans riche à pied qui lui
médecin légiste
on va pas tu applaudir à chaque fois
mais ça maintenant aux amériques jardin
par dieu or moi je suis un peu un peu
foufou et la tête et un peu déjanté un
peu
elle n'a personne à un peu délirante on
s'aime bien
parce qu'un drop y est bien la fille
pascal sevran blouson un pascal sevran
lui aubin il est y avait que quand
comment je dirais un jeu prend de
concept on voit là j'irai qmi les îles
et ses seins le ce le cercle chevalerie
ce voilier serpent de françois
mitterrand dans le du grand patron du
grand patron de la police dans la pièce
très bien bravo da fille denise fabre
ans denise fabre
elle a un rôle très copains qu'on n'en
parle pas charles aznavour jean les
mêmes chez le père du tueur
keep noir est dite 'noire' 7
c'est un personnage travail dans la
police et dirait qu'ils occupent plutôt
des affaires du showbiz
monsieur frédéric mitterrand
moi je suis un le commentateur d'un
enterrement gay séguin coluche
moi je joue le rôle d'un prof de gym
ouais mais bien et voyez comme je suis
je roule de pleureuses renault bah ouais
si vous les engeances est plutôt chiant
avec la zone h encore qui va ça revient
derrière qui va dans le métro pour
gueuler au monde entier la colère des
cités chanteur quelques pas gainsbourg
le beefeater locaux mais francis cabrel
francis cabrel ghislain rôle aux
primitifs france gall julio iglesias
rien voilà que c'est je fais un dos avec
renault
patrick bruel chanteur tient le droit ya
perdu de gauche yves montand j'ai géré
le j'ai mon propre rôle puisque je suis
chanteur dont expliqué eddy mitchell
chantois auger trois classes et on peut
l'applaudir
alors maintenant